my book is 58 pages i have already read
13 pages i plan to read five pages each
day until i finish the book
which equation could i use to find out
how many days d
it will take to finish reading the book
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
okay so let's first think about the
important information they're giving us
they're giving us the number of pages
that are in the book
they're giving us how much we've already
read we've already read 13 pages and
they also tell us how much we plan to
read i plan to read five pages each day
until the book is finished and then we
want an equation that it could use to
find how many days and d is how we're
going to represent the number of days
let me do that in the same color it'll
take to finish reading the book
all right so if we knew how many pages
we have to read and we were divided by
the fact that we're reading five pages
per day well then that would give us the
number of days so how many pages do we
have left to read in the book
well the book is 58 pages we've already
read 13 so we could subtract out 13 of
those so
this expression right over here this is
how many pages we have left in the book
let me write that down how many
how many
pages
left
and if we want to figure out how many
days it's going to take to read these we
would divide this by how many pages we
read each day and we see that we read 5
pages each day
so if we divide this by 5
then this whole expression let me do it
in this color
this whole expression is going to tell
us how
many
days left how many days
left
and so this is going to be equal to
d because d is the number of days left
to finish reading the book
now if we look at these choices that's
exactly what we have right over here in
choice c
we can make sure that these others don't
make sense 58 plus 13. no that would be
a situation where we're reading 13 pages
more than the number of pages that are
in the book that doesn't make sense and
that's happening for both choice a and
choice b it would also not make sense to
multiply by five because it's not going
to take you five times more than the
number of pages to read the book you're
going to divide by five you're reading
five pages every day
and we are done